he scatters the snowflakes
like birds are lighting the eye
is dazzled by their beautiful whiteness
and as they fall the mind is entranced
kate middleton is paying tribute to
prince philip in royal style
on saturday the duchess of cambridge
attended the intimate funeral service at
st
george's chapel at windsor castle
sporting a necklace that has
deep symbolism a four-strand pearl
necklace from queen elizabeth's personal
collection
pairing it with a fitted black coat and
a modest fascinator hat with a veil
[Music]
the necklace was once loaned to the late
princess diana by queen elizabeth
and has been worn by both the queen and
diana at public events
the necklace was originally a gift from
the japanese government
well this is going to be a royal funeral
like no other meghan markle who was
notably absent from the late prince's
funeral
also left special tribute alongside
prince harry
a sentimental wreath honoring a few
pieces of prince philip's life
like the national flower of greece to
represent his heritage
see holly to represent the royal marines
lavender for devotion
and companiola to signify gratitude and
everlasting love
the wreath also included a handwritten
note from the duchess of sussex
e.t has learned that megan watched the
service from home in california
her doctors would not clear her for
international travel
at this stage of her pregnancy megan and
harry are expecting baby number two
a girl later this year she was told
to stay behind so i think it of course
it's a difficult journey for prince
harry to make on his own
and she would have loved to have been
there to support him but they are
putting
her health the health of their unborn
baby first
and prince harry has come over to the uk
[Music]
alone
you